this joker actor may have had a serious
case of jealousy according to The
Hollywood Reporter Jared Leto who
portrayed the Joker in 2016 Suicide
Squad reportedly attempted to sabotage
director Todd Phillips and alone Joker
movie which stars Joaquin Phoenix in the
title role the outlet cites anonymous
sources that claim that I was so hurt by
and frustrated over the news that Warner
Brothers was moving ahead with another
Joker film that wasn't going to feature
him as the infamous DC Comics body that
he tried to kill the film before it
officially got off the ground
insiders with information about the
situation and whom thr claim are quote
familiar with letõs behavior have
indicated that Leto lodged bitter
complaints to his agents at the Creative
Artists Agency in Los Angeles the same
company that represents Joker director
Phillips after learning of the rifle
project let's say was said to have asked
his agents at CAA to stop Joker from
getting made allegedly claiming that the
mere existence of the project was
something of a slap in the face
the actor who won an Academy Award for
his work in Dallas buyers club
reportedly argued that quote he wasn't
being treated properly as an Oscar
winner additionally letter allegedly
asked his music manager Irving Azoff
and Entertainment executive who at the
time managed a toast band a thirty
Seconds to Mars the Contacts quote the
leader of Warner Brothers parent company
it's unclear whether lessor requested a
softer call Jeff Bewkes at Time Warner
or Randall Stephenson at AT&T as both
were head honchos at the time regardless
the alleged reason behind that OHS
inquiry to Azoff was to quote get
Warner's to kill the Phillips film it's
also been reported that Warner Brothers
executives were nervous about Joker
given its dark tone and gritty more
violent approach to the namesake comic
book characters origin the studio gave
the project the green light nonetheless
but approved a budget of only 55 million
dollars a sum that small in comparison
to other comic book movies and a budget
that some people at Warner Brothers were
reportedly hoping would frustrate
Phillips and caused him to abandon the
project altogether of course we know
that didn't end up happening a source of
letters has denied that the actor ever
tried to sabotage the Phoenix Phillips
Joker movie while Azoff who no longer
works with Leto declined to provide a
comment when thr reached out word of
Jared Leto reportedly trying to kill the
recently released Joker film comes
shortly after the Hollywood Reporter
claimed that the actor was alienated and
upset upon hearing the news that the
project's got the green lights lesser
reportedly also felt that Warner
Brothers have been teasing him with a
promise of his own standalone movie and
was heard that a different actor
received one instead now it seems at the
studio you may not have been serious
about putting together a solo Joker film
starring Leto as sources close to the
production of Suicide Squad have noted
that Warner Brothers wasn't thrilled
with letõs behavior prior to and drawing
the shooting of that movie let's hope
took an unorthodox approach to getting
into character for Suicide Squad which
included sending a live rat to Harley
Quinn actress Margot Robbie gifting
Deadshot actor Will Smith a love letter
and a bunch of bullets and bringing a
dead hog to rehearsal his terrifying
efforts really weren't worth it in the
end as Leto's Joker was little more than
a cameo in Suicide Squad another source
has claimed that let who tried to quote
invent a place for himself in the film
which was never really his movie and
that all backfired whatever caused
Warner Brothers to back away from a
letter let Joker movie and prioritize
Phillips project instead we can't say
for certain but it seems clear that Leto
didn't like how things played out sadly
for Leto sources have indicated to THR
that the actors time mr. Joker is
probably over he isn't included in birds
of prey which centers on Joker's ex
flame Harley Quinn played opposite Leto
in Suicide Squad by Margot Robbie and is
likely not going to be a part of the
upcoming Suicide Squad reboot slash
sequel directed by James Gunn the
filmmaker himself recently said that he
doesn't think it would be strange for
Leto's Joker to not be in the film quote
as he isn't part of the Suicide Squad in
the comics check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]